I'm here
(audience applauding)
with my dear old friend
and my absolute hero,
Seth Meyers, and joining us
is the Shirley Temple King himself,
and my other dear friend,
Leo Kelly!
(audience applauding)
Leo!
Leo, I understand you've created
a special beverage in honor of Seth's book?
Yes.
Thank you so much for having me
and it's great to meet you.
Great to meet you too.
(audience laughing)
So, I absolutely love the book that you made,
I'm Not Scared, You're Scared!
So, I created a special drink,
it's in the Shirley Temple universe,
it's called the Black Bear-y Shirley Temple,
inspired
(audience applauding)
by my favorite character
in the book, Bear.
(audience applauding)
I love it.
Very, very clever.
All right, Leo,
show us how it's done.
So, you're gonna take a glass,
put some ice,
and now, we're gonna take some Black Bear-y Seltzer,
That's right,
grrr
so, just add that in.
All right, and then we're gonna take
our Black Bear-y syrup,
Okay.
and now, let's just do it
until you think it's right,
not too dark,
but not too late.
I see,
I really like that you're not like bossy about it,
just do it
(bowl clinks)
until you think it's right.
Yeah.
And now, let's add a squirt of lime juice.
Okay.
You can do as much as you want.
I went big on the lime,
'cause I love a little
Same.
of that fresh citrus.
So, this is still in the Shirley Temple universe
and as you know,
Shirley Temples require cherries.
Yes, of course.
So, let's add
It is.
A cherry or two.
Okay.
I'm gonna do two.
I'm gonna add two.
Actually, I'm going
for the whole thing, yeah.
(bowl clinks)
And then is it cool
to just drink the cherry?
Yeah, why not?
Ugh!
I like cherries.
All, that's all good sugar?
Yeah.
(Drew chuckles)
Fresh cherry juice.
Yeah.
So, now,
(bowl clinks)
we'll add some actual,
the fruit, Black Bear-ies.
Yeah, great.
Black Bear.
Genius,
I love it.
So, let's add
as many as you want,
I'm gonna add three
Again, as many as you want.
I love the like--
As many as you want,
this isn't like--
I've gone to bartending school
and they're way worse than this.
(audience laughing)
They're like very specific doing that.
Now, when did you read the book?
I read the book...
I read it with my younger brother
and my sister last night and the day before,
because that book,
you can never get sick of,
it's so much adventure,
(audience laughing)
and there's many different ways
that you can look at it.
(audience applauding)
There's many different angles.
There's friendship,
there's courage,
there's bravery,
and there's adventure,
and I really like the adventure part.
You know, I wanna stress something,
Leo was not paid
to say any of that,
(audience laughing)
but...
(audience applauding)
But I am gonna slip him a little something
after the show.
(audience laughing)
Cheers
Cheers.
to that.
(Seth chuckling)
(glasses clink)
Thank you.
Leo, I love that.
I'm regretting you haven't been with me
for this entire press tour.
(audience laughing)
Thank you.
Leo, I just love you so much.
I'm so glad that I've been able
to find you in this world,
such a great partner.
In fact, I'd like to get your take on something.
Now, I pulled up a few pictures,
because I need some parent advice,
because I'm the bear here,
I'm a little afraid.
My daughter, Frankie, is turning eight.
She's one of those kids that loves
like death and cemeteries,
and asks about the afterlife all the time,
and this is the cake she wants.
All right.
(audience laughing)
And I'd like to show you
a series of invitations.
Ooh, I like that one.
This is one option,
she wants everyone to be--
We've come up with the word, spooky,
because death I thought,
I was like, "I don't know how to send that out
"to parents, Frankie."
Yeah, no,
spooky is good.
She's like,
"No, I want a death theme."
I'm like,
I'm scared as a parent to scare their parents,
so that's one option,
here's another,
this is kind of more
Ooh.
where she's at.
Okay.
I like the first one.
I'm just saying,
I really like the first one,
and also,
in the Monster Mash
it never says anything about Halloween,
so, at the party,
you could just be blasting it all day.
I love that,
and we wanna make it a costume party.
Yes, yeah.
And..
But she really wants everyone,
she's like, "I just am worried
"if you say it's a costume party,
"people are gonna come as princesses.
"I don't want any princesses,
"I only want death."
Mm-hmm.
(audience laughing)
(Drew chuckles)
I'm like,
So, yeah.
How do I put that on an invitation?
Death dress code?
I think spooky costumes.
Spooky?
Yeah,
I think if you say spooky costumes.
Oh, and before I go,
I have to ask you a few questions
about--
Let's do it.
So, when you were a kid,
what was your fear and how did you overcome it?
I was very afraid
of going too fast in anything,
for example, when I would go skiing,
my brother, who's younger than me,
would just race down the mountain,
and I was very sort of locked into the snowplow position.
And it did take me a long time
to have the courage to get up on stage
in front of people,
which is one day,
Leo, you will be able
to get up in front of people.
(audience laughing)
Oh, son of a gun,
you're already doing it.
Leo, you are way ahead
of where I (chuckles) was.
(audience applauding)
The perfect question, Leo.
As always,
my dear partner in crime,
Leo Kelly, thank you for helping me
navigate this show,
as well as life
and your beautiful bear,
Blackberry cocktail,
and Seth Meyers,
I'm Not Scared, You're Scared!
Which is such an amazing book,
is now out every everywhere.
Grab a copy and enjoy the read.
And Seth,
I'm so excited to be doing this with you,
who knew life would bring us here,
I'm so glad it did.
It was absolutely
(audience applauding)
a wonderful day
spent with you.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music fades)